okay we've before we've done a bunch of
different sort of giveaways and
discounts and promos for membership on
the program we've had some times like a
company will sponsor some free
memberships or something like that we've
had that we've had individuals who we
thanked and we say you know Joe Smith
from wherever has donated half of ten
memberships and then sometimes we have a
viewer or a member who wants to help us
out anonymously and that's what we have
today I haven't received any requests
for recognition but a longtime member
has sponsored half of 20 memberships for
new David Pakman show members he has
already paid thirty dollars each for
twenty people to get memberships meaning
that twenty of you can pay just the
other half of that sixty dollars and get
a half-price membership and the best
part of this is that this is not an
infomercial style low low introductory
price that then goes up and people lose
their minds you can keep the discounted
rate for as long as you like and twenty
memberships for us adding twenty members
in one go that's an important number for
us right we are still in the growth
phase of the David Pakman show so please
email in I want to make sure all 20 of
these memberships are spoken for because
a really supportive member has said I'm
going to contribute six hundred bucks so
that you can then gather 600 from
another twenty people through them
paying half-price membership so my only
concern whenever we do this Pat people
assume twenty memberships those are
gonna go in ten minutes I'm not even
gonna bother trying to get one and then
they don't email in and then we might
end up with a couple memberships left
over for a full week so don't assume
someone else has spoken for these Pat is
not allowed to get any of these half
priced memberships I'm not taking any of
them I'm not giving any away to you know
former producer Louis or former TV
director what Tom also known as Makana
Pakman or any of those people these are
only reserved for you and preferably for
new members that's the deal
I think I'm good on memberships I have
plenty of them myself
at this point and you gotta credit this
Good Samaritan I have no problem when
people say please acknowledge me but I
also think it's great when someone says
I don't need any acknowledgement they
just want to support the show so there's
only one way to get these half-price
memberships email in through our website
okay go to david pakman.com click on
contact say i'd like one of the
half-price memberships and i will get
the first 20 people to email in coupon
codes and you will be good to go with
the half-price membership and very
important you keep the discount for as
long as you keep the membership